foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
oh stop it
don't stop it don't stop it
happy Friday everyone as always on
Friday what do we do first we welcome
tonight's guests
oh look at that unlike Trinidad and
Tobago she only needs one name host of
Kennedy on Fox Business it's Kennedy
a Bargo
he's so sharp we're handing out
Band-Aids to the audience contributing
editor at The Spectator Chadwick Moore
she's so hip grandpas want her as a
replacement yeah Fox News contributor
tattoo
and when he steps out of the shower the
National Weather Service issues a fog
warning pretty good
that's a good one my massive sidewick at
the NWA World Heavyweight Champion
oh
that was a lot of work
before we get to some news stories it's
Friday so it's time to braid my hair I
kid it's time for this
Greg's leftovers hmm
yeah I love them you love them so let's
love them together it's leftovers where
I read the jokes we didn't use this week
and as always it is my first time
reading these so if they suck it's not
my fault
it's yours
a massive humpback whale has died after
beaching itself on Long Island Monday
morning authorities believe it may have
become disoriented once it was separated
from the other members of The View
that's a good
off to a good start
Democrat congresswoman Ilan Omar is dry
heat for claiming she was unaware there
are quote tropes about Jews and money
but she clearly hasn't learned from her
mistake when she asked to Jewish leaders
penny for your thoughts
oh yeah
a convicted rapist aren't they all in
Scotland allegedly changed his identity
so he would be placed in the woman's
jail to avoid confusion Scottish
officials have given him an appropriate
code name the goodness monster
you actually like that one love it
yeah sports fans are complaining that
Super Bowl tickets are Out Of Reach for
everyone but the one percent but the
WNBA is reminding fans that their
courtside seats are still six bucks
the 29 year old woman allegedly used
fake documents to enroll in a New Jersey
high school
it reminded some of Nancy Pelosi
sleeping in a freezer to convince voters
she's only 400.
I didn't see that direction
I thought it was going to go somewhere
else anyway a group of vegan activists
blocking traffic we're we're nearly hit
by a livestock truck that refused to
stop
undaunted the activists returned the
next day demanding to be run over by an
electric car
a study published in early January
suggests men take Viagra men taking
Viagra maybe adding years to their life
however men who die while taking the
pills are asked not to have open casket
funerals
very hard to close them
in a recent interview Bill Gates
continued to downplay his connection to
convicted pedophile Jeffrey Epstein
claiming they were only dinner Pals
although Gates should have been
suspicious when he had to order off the
children's menu
damn
that was a good one
yeah
Pete Davidson was unrecognizable
isn't he always
was unrecognizable at a recent Knicks
game when he showed up with a new buzz
cut how embarrassing you know to be seen
at a Knicks game
[Laughter]
a spy balloon that was spotted over the
United States was confirmed to be
operated by China authorities fear it
may be part of a Chinese plot to drop up
to ten thousand takeout menus
that was good
very good
very good it's funny because it's true
and finally Will Smith and Martin
Lawrence are re-teaming for a fourth Bad
Boys movie in the latest film the Aging
will and Martin will face their biggest
challenge yet enlarged prostates
you're very uh
you're very diplomatic I give that a
solid B for the leftovers I mean you
don't get food poisoning but you you
know you laughed and that's all that
matters now I want to some news he
messed with drugs and Tarts now his
story is falling apart
but can they keep the walls from closing
in on Biden families sins well Hunter
hope so as his story collapses like a
hooker oding at a motel 6. his lawyer
turned to two Delaware prosecutors with
deep ties to the bited family to probe
the infamous laptop probe that laptop be
careful
the laptop Hunter said wasn't his but
somehow has his homemade smut on it
sorry pal that excuse didn't work for me
and it's not going to work for you
meanwhile Harvard has pulled the plug on
a disinformation research project that
was led by a skeptic of the laptop
Scandal the university reportedly cited
bureaucratic reasons
a woman named Joan Donovan ran the
project
here she is in a tweets from April 2022
I believe that's her on the right
I think
well who knows who knows these days
right she could be on the left good for
her good verb she's both maybe she's
two-headed
she tweeted the hunter laptop under
Biden laptop was a straw man argument
fair enough Hunters had more straws up
his nose than a sea turtle
rip sea turtle but now she's got so much
egg on her face supermarkets charge six
bucks just to look at her
President Biden meanwhile secured a 250
000 line of credit against his Delaware
Beach House according to records did Fox
digital obtained really nope no one
knows why the credit line was taken out
and the white house does not deny that
the money is being used for cocaine and
horse
mainly because no one asked if it's
being used for cocaine and horse I
wonder what Joe thinks
yeah we took a home
[Music]
pairs fix the gutters and re-tile the
bathroom come on of course we needed it
for lawyers of course we did
hookers and lawyers that's all hunter
ever spent his money on
I told him they'll both screw you about
only one of them's worth doing a refi on
the beach house
all right
Kennedy right two elements to this
monologue you got the hunter Biden's
legal uh strategy which looks like it's
blown up in his face not the first time
and and then you got the disinformation
office this is like the second or third
one that shut down since they were
sprouted at post Trump what is your take
on either and or both
Greg I've answered this question
thoroughly several times I've been here
all week answering this question and now
I'm going to have to refer you to White
House counsel
so it's it's very interesting because
you know here's a guy who wants it all
ways he he wants the uh the laptop story
to be false he wants everything in there
to be manufactured by pro-trump Russian
agents he also wants his laptop back uh
he wants the cred that comes from the
wean Flex which he does constantly I I
don't know I mean I I bet there are
professional pornographic stars who
don't have that much photographic
evidence of their junk I mean it really
is an obsession yeah it is and even the
corrupt commies who are paying millions
of dollars like this is what we got when
we sent him a giant diamond and a
million bucks a year to sit on this
board and that board and the access
wasn't even worth it because his dad
forgot about it and now he wants to sick
the federal government and that's not
how it works civilians don't go
um by the way I want a federal probe of
that guy in the funny Scottish hat who
fixed my Mac because even though I told
him to crack my back he's not supposed
to do that
you're absolutely right this is the
weirdest part Chadwick is that the
Hunter's lawyers are saying you guys got
to go after the dude who uh Hunter hired
to what do whatever whatever and the guy
like held on to it tried to contact him
and somehow he's the villain I don't
understand the cap either
it's a thing obviously I don't know I
don't know what or to whom he's
signaling but yes yeah well this is the
first time in American history that a
president and his son have both been
under investigation at the same time
which I was delighted to learn about but
it's um it's interesting it it's
actually horrific to watch this family
that owns the state of Delaware along
with the credit card companies which
probably own them go after basically
this guy who owns a repair shop who I
think was charging 86 dollars to Hunter
or something for that for the repair
just wanted his money and left multiple
messages come pick up your laptop and uh
Hunter signed a contract that says if
you leave it there for over 90 days it
becomes a property of the shop uh so to
watch them sort of bring out Bazookas to
come after this poor guy and I think
that's uh this is like Scranton Joe
isn't it who looks like for the working
guy yeah uh apparently not
um but uh yeah uh I don't know what's
gonna happen but I doubt that Hunter's
gonna face any rule well that sucks well
actually you know it doesn't suck at
because I'm not beneath saying that I
can't wait for the televised hearings
you're going to have sex drugs it's
going to be wild you're going to have
millions perhaps billions of dollars
funneled here and there we're gonna
watch it every day we might not even
have to work
if they have it wall to wall and it goes
on to the night we might not even have a
show
we could just hang out yeah
drink lady drinks
yeah it's crazy though that they've they
were all just living this life the
entire time yeah we're hearing about it
but this was going on and they're all
just we didn't know I mean and like
Hunter calling employees of Joe like you
gotta help me with this you gotta help
me like I never called anyone at my
parents work yeah except
except when I was like little yeah and I
would call them to say can I please talk
to my mom so she can tell my sister to
stop biting my brother
but she would actually get mad at me
about that she'd be like you're in
trouble for letting them fight I'm like
I'm not selling tickets yeah but like
Joe's just like okay with this it's
crazy and then just quickly the fact
that that Harvard program the
misinformation program was led by a
woman who fell for a misinformation
campaign reminds me of a horror movie
for three reasons why because a lot of
us saw the ending coming there were a
lot of warnings along the way and by the
end we all found out the call was coming
from inside the house yes
very true
I love it I love that all these
disinformation officers that are
imploding isn't it the best do you have
any advice for Hunter
well let's stop this for a minute okay
all right let's just slow down here okay
I know what the Hat was okay I know what
the Hat was okay a guy wears a lot of
hats yeah it was the director's hat okay
he forced poor Hunter to make adult Skin
Flicks
that's what it was that's what the
laptop was from that was the camera yes
okay and he was blackmailing a crackhead
for 89 that's a lot of money when you're
a crackhead
because you got to buy your crack yes
and then you know and you got it then 89
it's like do I buy more crack or do I
pay off my porn director yes
Very Yes tight it's a tough situation
it's so bad that his parents one is a
doctor the other one's the president he
smokes so much crack they got to get a
loan on the house to pay his legal bills
that's a lot of crack
what could the London what other job
could his dad possibly get to cover
those expenses yeah he literally could
raise our taxes to pay his son's crack
bill
and it's still not enough that would be
a great thing I would actually like are
we sure the gas prices it wasn't a
little loophole
Hunter's crack
thank you Americans
all right
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else